I was already hanging out with some idiots at the entrance to the barrier, so I let my guard down, the
gas mask guy who was in the barrier, and tried to get in. He's making a
big show of it. Hey, what
should I do? You
didn't listen to what I said earlier, but at a time like this.  I don't
know if it's transparent or what, but I think it
's okay if you ask your friends to do something about it. What's
wrong with you? Oh, and you just called me a small fry,
right? No, D-rank.  No matter how you
look at it, you're still a small fry.If we don't
find a candidate soon, we'll be at a disadvantage.Anyway, let's
go down, let's go for now.We can't force it
through this sea of ​​fire.We
can't do anything about it.  Hey, I
just can't do it!
So what is that? Do you always carry emergency food with you? You
need meat when you use your abilities. You
can't do anything, so just shut up and
get it. [Music] Run, seriously, hurry up. Get some of this.